Voiceover:What I want to do in this video
is further connect our understanding
of the binomial theorem.
Two combinatorics, two Pascal's triangle.
Just to review the ideas again,
if we're taking x plus
y to the third power
and I'm just using this as an example
that's a little bit easy to get around,
get our heads around
that's essentially taking
three equivalent expressions
and multiplying them by each other.
You're taking x plus y, times x plus y,
times x plus y.
Let's call this the first x plus y,
the second x plus y,
and the third x plus y.
If you're looking at the expansion of it
and you're saying well how many ways
can we construct x y squared
or another way to think about it is
you have these three expressions,
you're going to choose two of them
to contribute a y and take the product.
For example, you could pick expression one
and expression two to contribute the y.
You could pick expression
one and expression three
to contribute the y,
or you could take expression two
and expression three to contribute the y.
Of course the other expressions
what's going to contribute to the x.
You have three expressions
and you're going to choose two
to contribute the y
and so that's why you have
this combinatorics idea
it's three choose two.
It's the exact same mathematical problem,
if you have three friends
and you're choosing two
to ride in a car with you,
you don't care which sit
they are going to sit in.
You're just saying which two friends
get to ride in my two
seater or get to ride,
what are the two friends
that I'm going to pick?
Same way here, out of three friends
which are the two that I'm going to pick
to contribute a y to this product
and then the third is
going to contribute an x.
Now let's go to Pascal's triangle
and hopefully see that this is actually
a very similar idea.
We could go to the same term,
so the x y squared term,
so that's right over there.
Pascal's triangle, I always
visualize it as a map.
This is a node in the map
and I think what are the different ways
that I can get to this node on the map.
I could have a y squared,
and then multiplied by an x.
Since we're multiplying an x
that's why I made this line orange
or I could have an x y
and I could multiply by a blue
so there's two immediate things above it
that I can get to them
but there's two ways to get to this one,
there's one way to get to this one,
and so the combined
ways to get to this one
is two plus one is equal to three.
Just to make it the connection
between what we just said,
what's really going on here
is at each of these
nodes as we pick a path,
we're essentially saying
are we picking an x or y
from each of these expressions.
We number the expressions,
let's number them here.
Let's say this is expression one,
this is expression two,
this is expression three.
We said that there's three paths
that we could take us here,
let's mark them out.
There's this path,
there's this path right
over here that gets us there
and that's equivalent to picking the x
from expression one.
Notice we picked the left hand side
then we go to the right hand side.
We pick the y from expression two,
and then we pick the y
from expression three,
the last two, we pick the right path,
we picked the blue path.
That's essentially one way
that we could choose two y's
out of these three expressions.
Once again, one way to choose two y's
out of three expressions
but we don't care about just that one,
we care about all of the different paths.
This was one way,
another way would be to go like this.
Pick a y from the first one,
an x from the second one
and a y from the third one.
Or pick a y from the first expression,
a y from the second expression
and an x from the third expression.
It's really a kind of
fundamental mathematical level.
It's solving the exact same problem.
Hopefully this gives
you a little intuition
on why Pascal's triangle is connected
to two combinatorics
and why they're both useful
for finding binomial expansions.